so before I get started I have to say I
absolutely love Cloud Atlas and I just
need to say I think it's a masterpiece
and I'm out and it's all I have yeah
absolutely love it so I just had to
address that and now we can talk about
um this is uh for both of you this is
Mary Poppins the original is such a
classic film what was it like meeting
Rob for the first time and sort of the
conversation of him saying to you hey so
I'm thinking I want you and Mary Poppins
returns it was an incredible
conversation it's one of the meetings
with directors that I've had in my life
that I will remember most because I
walked in and not really knowing what to
expect I'd only just been called the
night before to and told that I should
go and meet Rob Marshall and he was
thinking about making Mary Poppins and I
I didn't really have much in my head to
expect but by the time I came out of the
room and by the time he'd pitched me his
kind of vision for the movie I was so
overwhelmed with excitement and I just I
brought my agents immediately I said I
just have to be part of this I want to
help this guy tell this story and he
really I don't know we worked some magic
spell on me in that meeting which he's
worked over this entire production I
think he's he's done something so
special and he was inspiring right from
the very beginning I am completely agree
with everything he said what was your
question yet I am listening I am paying
attention I am I really am oh I'll
switch it to you one of the I'll switch
the question Emily said to me that the
you guys or she called Rob the silent
assassin because he would get you to be
able to do anything just by looking at
you and like whispering you're gonna do
this it'll be great is that true yeah I
mean but it wasn't as as as overt as
that makes it sound you never knew quite
what he was doing - he's very I guess
he's just incredibly loving yeah and and
because I suppose the worst thing is
when you feel a director
has been coerced into costing you or
someone else thought you were good
living or some notion like that you
might have but with Rob you never have
any doubt that he wanted you he thinks
you're the person to do it he's given
the part to you and he trusts you
completely to - I think she said it
because she convinced he convinced her
to do the thing with the Umbrella he did
persuaded to do some frightening thing
yes yeah true so true I've always heard
in movies you don't want to work with
animals you don't want to work with kids
but the kids in this movie are
incredible can you sort of talk about
working with these three young actors
and what maybe surprised you or what it
was like working with them I think I am
here and it was amazing it was amazing
to watch because they were so
professional when they they were a
professional within us they'd never have
behaved like they knew everyone's lines
including obviously their own but all of
ours as well as if we ever forgotten
they were just a kid and they got quite
annoyed yeah come on
they great teachers of acting because
you know they're just so in it and they
but up until the moment that the camera
turns over they're running around and
telling stupid jokes and laughing and
and then they and then someone says turn
over and there they are absolutely right
there with you and and it's all because
they just have such enthusiasm for what
they're doing and they're so they have
such belief in what they're doing that
they're completely full of absolute
conviction and I think it you can learn
so much from watching watching these
kids perform then how they are on a set
it's I loved watching them
you